Translator: Katja Tongucer
Reviewer: TED Translators admin
(Music)
♫ I don't understand myself, ♫
♫ why they keep talking of love, ♫
♫ if they come near me, ♫
♫ if they look into my eyes and kiss my hand. ♫
♫ I don't understand myself, ♫
♫ why they talk of magic, ♫
♫ that no one withstands, ♫
♫ if he sees me, if he passes by. ♫
♫ But if the red light is on ♫
♫ in the middle of the night ♫
♫ and everybody listens to my song, ♫
♫ then it is plain to see. ♫
♫ My lips, they give so fiery a kiss, ♫
♫ my limbs, they are supple and soft. ♫
♫ It is written for me in the stars, ♫
♫ thou shalt kiss, thou shalt love. ♫
♫ My feet, they glide and float, ♫
♫ my eyes, they lure and glow. ♫
♫ And I dance as if entranced, 'cause I know, ♫
♫ my lips give so fiery a kiss. ♫
♫ In my veins, ♫
♫ runs a dancer's blood, ♫
♫ because my beautiful mother ♫
♫ was the Queen of dance ♫
♫ in the gilded Alcazar. ♫
♫ She was so very beautiful, ♫
♫ I often saw her in my dreams. ♫
♫ If she beat the tambourine ♫
♫ to her beguiling dance,
all eyes were glowing admiringly. ♫
♫ She reawakened in me, ♫
♫ mine is the same lot. ♫
♫ I dance like her at midnight ♫
♫ and from deep within I feel: ♫
♫ My lips, they give so fiery a kiss, ♫
♫ my limbs, they are supple and soft. ♫
♫ It is written for me in the stars, ♫
♫ thou shalt kiss, thou shalt love. ♫
♫ And I dance as if entranced,
'cause I know, ♫
♫ my lips give so fiery a kiss. ♫
(Applause)